here they come jeff has told us so much
about you he's told me so much about
both of you too
and you came anyway
what did you think the first time you
read this script because
i can't imagine it was like oh that's
great got it let's go i
there must have been some sort of
reaction to it it's there's so much
going on
i despise okay that's it i've got it
let's go
i like things to be a little more
complex than that
i just found it unbelievably
poetic and brave and bonkers
you had to read it a couple of times and
i had to speak to charlie to
like fully the thing is you can watch it
and you could make all kinds of
assumptions about what's going on
or just kind of hone in on different
things depending on your
life experience and who you are so i
just he's very reluctant charlie to
i mean he has to talk about it with us
but to kind of pre-determine
people's experience of it because it is
so
kind of abstract and
um yeah i don't know how to talk about
it
i think bonkers is a good word um
because i remember i watched it and sort
of went i do not know what i just saw
but the next day i was like i have so
many ideas about what i just saw
yes it's a great conversation starter it
will make people
think and appreciate and wonder
um i i just think actually the film is
very reflective of charlie himself he's
such a
sensitive complex kind of filmmaker and
the story is jam-packed and
just imbued with so many different ideas
um it's not like it's like way out there
i say bonkers because the ground kind of
keeps moving
and it's not always obvious but
that's a great thing it's very freeing
as an actor to not have any
anything kind of holding you in that's
kind of no rules
well that's what david said in the um
the notes there's no rules of filmmaking
or acting apply when you launch into
this material and that must be exciting
very much so and we all felt that way so
it made it even better because
there are some scenes where all four of
us are talking and it feels like a
conversation but it's also like stream
of consciousness like we're all part of
the one mind
um and for all of us to kind of have
this reverence for charlie and for the
material and wanting to make it as great
as possible it just made us
i don't know want to be
there for each other we had to be it was
like the best possible acting experience
great you you're jake's mom we
you play her in kind of multiple bursts
and forms i guess we would say
um some of them older younger some of
them feel
like memories how do you approach
playing a character like that when
you're playing her in so many
different iterations but also through so
many different lenses of other people i
don't know if that's a
question that makes sense but maybe
people see the film it'll make more
sense
it will make more sense and it's very
difficult because i don't want to give
anything away but
the question makes absolute sense to me
well
um i think because you know on my first
day of shooting i
sat in this chair and i was in front of
a green screen and i was going to be
placed into a scene that they were
shooting after i'd left
and moved on um and i remember sitting
there thinking
how do i go about this i feel so
um disconnected from some i don't even
quite understand what it's going to be
so how can i contribute now
and charlie said to me there are no
rules in life and that is
literally what i ran with for the entire
film we all did and that
that becomes incredibly freeing um and i
guess my main
concern was
just having some kind of through line
for the character in each kind of point
in her life
but people change also people people can
change in some ways and not in others so
there was you kind of couldn't go wrong
you know what i mean
it really was a lot of
there was a lot of opportunity and a lot
of different things to play with
um and my biggest you know i just didn't
want
to get to the point where i'm playing
her at 92 and i just didn't want it to
feel two-dimensional or that people were
kind of looking at the
prosthetics as a bit of a novelty i
still wanted people to
feel the connection between jake and his
mum when she is that age
so i don't know i don't know how people
will feel but
i mean it's a great performance and i
think one of the very things that people
can latch on to
even if they don't get the film or
whatever they see in the trailer is the
laugh
that you deliver at some point and i'm
wondering
how did you come up with that laugh it's
so it feels like you're putting your
entire soul into it
i think um i just love working with
contradictory elements
and this woman is trying to be effusive
and trying to welcome this young girl
into home and she's trying to give her
son
space but she's it's clear that she
smothered him his entire life
and so there's so much push and pull
that i just want
i kind of physically wanted you you want
to see that she's trying and she's
smiling and she's laughing and she's
trying to engage but it's all so
painful um as long as i had those
two things rubbing up against each other
it seemed to feel
feel right you know in the moment
and um you know you've had a few
excruciating dinner scenes
on screen um recently and
i was wondering who you'd rather have
dinner with annie graham at the peak of
her hysteria or
or jake's mom in one of her many
iterations
oh my god what an offer i'll decline on
all
right i'm washing my hair lady
you're not you're not in for the ham
dinner no i'm not gonna go there
at least with i'm thinking of ending
things
it'll all kind of keep shifting but
there would be no escape
with uh that just was what it was that
wasn't changing that was the thing she
was just eyeing it
all the way to the end absolutely
so you're you know i don't spoil things
but you're in sort of this film for a
section and you weren't there
every day on set um and i'm wondering
have you seen the complete thing now um
and what was your reaction wow
i mean i read the the script in entirety
i
knew what the story was but
um it is unashamedly out there
and not in a kind of you know not in any
kind of
shocking or manipulative way it's just
that
life is change and the changes come
thick and fast
in this and they are kind of extreme and
it can be disconcerting and a lot of
people have been saying they find it
unnerving and that's probably
a good way of putting it yeah i i
was unnerved throughout so well done
um it sounds like you were a fan of
charlie's work before you got to work
with him and i'm wondering was there a
film that he'd made in the past that was
a favorite of yours um or that you know
you you
you really connected with um i i have
loved
everything that he's done either as a
writer or writer director all of it i
think he is just an incredible mind and
offers something so unique to film goers
and he's a true artist and a total
inspiration um so yeah i mean
i was kind we almost worked together we
we met a few times and emailed
on other projects um i would say one of
my favorite films of all time is
eternal sunshine of the spotless mind um
but you know i hadn't seen an anamaleesa
and i watched it while we were making
this and i just loved it it was so
incredible
so everything he does is just
i think if you're an artist say
something and he does he takes his
opportunity and he
he really contributes yeah
and you're about to work or you're
currently working uh with another
great um celebrated director about which
i'm sure you're not going to say
anything
but i'm curious have you had you shot
any of nightmare ally yourself
before the before the pandemic closing i
tried on wigs i'd tried on clothes
rehearsing with david strathan and
hadn't stepped on set
and then had to get on a plane and those
come home
close are you excited to play this
character
yeah but i've had so long to think about
it that it's becoming
like i don't even like to have a lengthy
rehearsal period because there's only so
much you can say
it's all in the doing for me and it's
all kind of
and in the moment ultimately in the
moment um so
just having time to think about
something for too
long i just don't like that but anyway
you let go of it all and whatever
happens in the moment happens so
it's an incredible collection of actors
really talented people
on and off screen and the story is
incredible
it's like a visual feast it's going to
look so just beautiful
like all of his pieces and guillermo
um i mean his energy is infectious he
has been creating this world for a long
time
and he
i don't know i don't know what it's
going to be like
we have a real connection a rare and
intense attachment
i've never experienced anything like it
i'm thinking of ending things huh what
did she say something what was it about
uh ian reed's book that
that appealed to you and made you think
this is something i want to tackle
a couple of things one is i really like
the dreaminess of it and two i felt that
it was doable
on a smaller budget it was very
contained in terms of cast and
locations and um i also liked the idea
of being so contained of having most of
it in a car
even though there was something kind of
scary about that it appealed to me to
like
try to be able to figure out how to make
that interesting um
to make it work so i'd say that those
are the reasons
yeah and so many of the themes
at least in the first part of your own
book and kind and
for anyone watching go and get mankind
it's great if you love charlie's work
um seem to have bled in here um
or at least there seems to be so much
crossover and i'm wondering
how much did eight years of working on
that novel affect your approach to
this film that's a tough question i
don't know i mean i feel like
maybe in some ways it was like a
vacation to work on this because of the
because of the novel
um in that sense i felt less um
intimidated by the process because i've
been writing so much for so long
especially towards the end of the novel
when i was desperately trying to finish
it i was writing you know for
four or five hours a day which is not
something that i normally do
um but in terms of themes i guess there
are probably themes that are in
all of the things i do some of the
themes are present in ian's book
already and some of them probably most
of them and and some of them are things
that i think about
like um i'm not even sure i'd have to
think about the book in the and the
movie i mean certainly like the aging
thing and the memory thing and the
um fantasy thing and all of that stuff
is kind of present in most things that i
do so
uh in freeways or at least highways
highway life seems to be something
you mean because they're they're too the
two driving things in the book
that's a coincidence yeah i just sort of
yeah yeah that's a coincidence i mean
though
when i got ian's book i'd already was
well into and kind so yeah
the fact that there's like a fast food
place in and kind and there's the other
thing
that the ice cream place uh struck me
but
it pre-existed you know and i like it
and i like i like both images i like the
knight
and the thing in the middle of nothing
um you added
i believe because i haven't actually
read ian's book unfortunately but
you did add the oklahoma and musical
element um
right and and why did you decide to
introduce that element to the story
well there are things that i changed
about ian's book that required me to
spend more time in the high school
than the book does and and i was trying
to create the life
of a high school with a janitor at night
and i thought there would be a play
rehearsal um
and then i thought about oklahoma
because it um is a play that i was
familiar with and
also um i'd been in it when i was a
little kid and
um so and then when i started to rethink
oklahoma i realized that there are a lot
of sort of parallel themes in oklahoma
that
that that are in the in the story i was
telling so it seemed perfect
perfectly suited for it so that's where
it came from
one other element of this and and kind
is this real interest
or at least reference to film critics
and film
criticism and you know i mean there's at
length quotes in this of pauline kale
etc and obviously
um b is a film critic um i'm wondering
is there you know rotten tomatoes i'm
curious is there a film critic
that you go you beeline to and that
whose work you love
um and why no i i don't i mean there are
people i like and
i'm i'm but i i don't like there's
anybody that i i go to
um and um i did like pauline kale
you know when she was around
uh and i was young um but
um i haven't revisited her except for
this in a really long time
was she right about a woman under the
influence no
i don't think so but i think that was
the thing i was exploring was that he
was intimidated by
her opinion and he couldn't he couldn't
sit with his opinion because
he felt like she was smarter than than
he was so that was that was sort of what
was at play there
it's me no it was me i tell you
i would misplace my own head if it
wasn't screwed onto my own head how many
times did you read it
the first time you you got this script
from charlie to sort of
get your head around it um we can go
with buckley first
well when i got it i think it was like
you know one of those secret
um scripts that kind of explode after 12
hours
i didn't have like a you know infinite
time with
sitting with it which is probably a good
thing um
so i think i probably read it once or
twice and uh
then let's kind of saw what happened
so i went in to put myself into it but
yeah
right and and what about you jesse i
i only read it once before i talked to
charlie which
did not feel like that was anywhere near
enough but i
know that i was in um and then after
that
yeah at least
10 times or so before before we got
there and then
just started to read it as much to get
familiar with
with the dialogue so much dialogue guys
i was
watching those scenes there must have
been 15 page scenes how did you
how did you guys handle like learning it
all and then
sitting in that car together for for two
weeks just getting through it
yeah i i walked around london with me
quite a lot before i came over to
uh new york and actually even before i
came to new york i was i'd get a visa so
i was like stuck in a limbo
in canada for about a week and had
nothing else to do so
he kind of walked around toronto for me
for a while as well
um and then you just gotta
leave it all and see what happens once
you get to set and
i think if you have a kind of sense of
where you're
or well i didn't really know where i was
going to be venturing but
things just start coming out of their
own
being once you get to set
and uh jesse we had moved into
our new house not all that long
before we got the script and this was
the longest period of time that we had
actually
been here and we had so
much just junk from the other place
that had you know piled up
and so i was like going through
all this mostly just old trash
while i was like
old old memories that you know we're
tucked away in a drawer or whatever and
then
yeah there was some talk someone thought
they felt a presence in our house and
there was one one night that i was
looking at the script and saw like a
reflection of something in the window
what what is it i mean how would you
describe
charlie and working with him as a
director if you had to succinctly give
another actor the idea what they're
going to be in for
how would you how would you describe it
he's the most
like beautiful vulnerable
gigantic brilliant-minded
friend that you can ever have on set
um he's he's gorgeous
in every way and um
yeah the most lovable the most lovable
man and like everybody on set everybody
on set was like
like all the creatives like from the
crew and the
props guys and like the lighting like
they were like
they were willing every ounce towards
charlie
for the sheer fact of what he created
and
what they what they were allowed to like
work in you know and to be muscular in a
uh
and that was a feeling towards charlie
from everybody everybody
wills the best for for him because we
all
respect and love and he's just
an incredible human being i mean
everything jesse just said but i will
say i don't i don't know if i've ever
seen why
you seldom see a crew from top to bottom
that is
this invested and we had a
we had a gaffer that had got really sick
and he started
to get a fever and he told us
when he came back to work that he was
having these hallucinations
and yeah and the young woman were in
this hotel room and then the
like maggot infested pig was there
everyone was really yeah because of
because of charlie you just
uh it's it's so unique and it and it
just
it affects everyone in such a different
way and you just want to give everything
you have because he's
so brilliant obviously but such a
pleasure to work with i know everyone
says that
but it's truer than it's ever been you
[Music]
we're know and time
passes through us
[Music]
blowing my cold wind
[Music]
maybe this is how it was always going to
[Music]
end